speaking of working out this is this
ain't even really funny but
you know i was watching something on
instagram
now my instagram feed is just filled
with nine-year-old boxers it's so
demoralizing why
because they're so good oh okay i'm like
well
and by the way i finally watched you
know kyle talking to khabib
that was way funnier khabib's commented
to kyle when he said oh
i want to fight jorge mosby the first
thing he says is how old are you
he says i'm 27. he says ah it's too late
for this
it was the most i feel like that one
just went under the radar
because it was wait who said that about
who khabib said that to kyle from milk
oh oh okay cause kyle from elk was
saying oh jorge mosby doll [ __ ] my
right right right right i watched that
yeah yeah yeah so
he says i older he says i'm 27. he said
it's too late for this
maybe with dog and i i thought that was
just i feel like everyone slept on the
fact that it's so
goddamned that it's such a burn yeah
yeah yeah
not gonna happen yeah you need help you
need help to get in a fight
it's physically impossible yeah for you
to win that at this point
i mean granted he's talking about you
know a pro fighter but i don't know i
felt like that one
anyway so i see all these little kids on
my feet
um and and so one of them was this kid
was a bit older but he was doing that
neck
uh workout you know that head strap
where you can put a small plate on it
yeah you like lift your yeah yeah this
is so tough
i i just pictured some kind of soccer
mom class
i'm like a berries oh no
like a berries boot camp but it's all
the middle-aged women
trying to there's some big ass dude at
the front like come on
you want to learn to suck that dick
i want to learn i want to lose that andy
dick yeah no they're teaching them
how to give head remember yeah yeah yeah
yeah that was like a famous what the
[ __ ] movie is that
i don't know but then i definitely
remember that one
uh act actor with the cucumber like he
just hard customer
blowing the [ __ ] out of that thing
we gotta find that clip i remember me my
my boy were like
[Laughter]
that's when i we got we were
mad we got introduced to the idea of the
of the like the pepper grinder kind of
early
dude we i i was listening to a clip from
a david dobrik podcast that just popped
up on my recommended
and he was talking about how like him
and his buddies used to have sleepovers
where they'd all
jerk off but like they'd go like they'd
find a porn link
and they'd all watch it and they'd all
go to the bathroom one time
and jerk off and then come back and the
his buddies would be like you have fun
is it yeah it was dope and then the next
guy would go
yeah i'm like this is the most little
kid [ __ ] of all time like yeah
no secret yes this is it right here just
like [ __ ] no
social awareness about sex or anything
you're just discovering things
and so like imagine that just like being
normal they just they just got
unknowingly they just created
you know a little bit of amsterdam a
little slice and all yeah
put in a quarter go beat off that's
crazy so would they all like share the
laptop
i don't know i don't know i stopped
listening after that i was like [ __ ]
absurd yeah i'm good
no thank you i'm all good i'm all set
for this thank you uh
positive hey yo sam yeah yeah as i was
thinking we could
really confuse girls and just be like
yeah that's what we do even now
when you're when we're having boys
nights that's what's happening i'll just
hit the bathroom one yeah one at a time
at a time spank it yeah
and you know we make sure to wash hands
before dapping each other up
hell yeah poker night
poker night yeah more like poke a hole
in my boxers
all right the secret to a good dj is oh
this was an old school
careful how did i forget that is it old
like your husband of 10 years
or just some hot sailor you met at tgi
friday we literally can't show this
i think we can a couple months oh this
is the white from entourage that's who
it is
um who never did she's not jack but did
leave me with a little something called
herpes
which i all right let's just get to the
good part
and they just start
yeah we can't believe this uh
bro you gotta hit this moment this [ __ ]
is so funny
wait it's gonna we're gonna get
copyrighted for this that's what i meant
yeah go on go on
it wasn't playing music before though oh
god i gotta go music
yeah just playing on mute got it yeah
yeah
what are we doing this is this is no
[ __ ] better than david and his
friends
that's so funny we're talking about that
and then this no no no this is
hilarious look at the way they're
holding it
okay like i love how
they're selling the confusion so well
like how she's just holding that [ __ ]
like a candle
yeah it's just like why are you holding
it from the base how would you ever hold
a real dick like that
that's just holding it like an [ __ ]
yeah just you know just like a
like she's at like a [ __ ] like a car
crash vigil or something like she's
gonna light
a bunch of you know candles right
like with this one candle
oh my god this is absurd
oh my god
oh yeah he goes no no too much you know
what i've been blessed in the first what
does he say
well we can't we'll never we'll never
know [ __ ]
bruh yes
[Music]
oh my god
this is so funny man i thought for some
reason i remember using two hands but
whatever holy [ __ ]
i would remember the brown girl out of
all of them
anyway anyway
bro that [ __ ] i'm sorry that from the
base handle it's
killing me dude you got to hold this
dick from the back
shoulder [ __ ] like a grilled cheese or
something don't trip
anyways yeah so i was just picturing
it's a line of these moms like
their knees just ripping sets
yeah come on come on you want to last
longer or what
just show your man you got that stamina
come on
show him why he picks you over his
secretary
so mom i'm the secretary i'm the
secretary i'm a secretary
ow [ __ ] ow ow ow oh and then
and then and then a class then another
class of secretaries is walking by
and then they see the moms like are you
guys training good luck
yeah yeah yeah and they have a [ __ ]
45 pound plate hanging from their neck
you're gonna need it yeah they're just
walking they just flip it over their
shoulder that woman works for my husband
[Laughter]
three three just early twenties girls
with plates
walking around the gym look at those old
hags
suffering with ten pounds that's the new
only fans category
next string yeah next string
all kinds of girls and traps just
[ __ ] looking like a [ __ ] pit bull
on all fours in front of the camera was
good
what are you watching uh nothing nothing
i was trying to think what's a crazy
only fans
uh type of content we could make
um excuse me sorry like for real make
sure i just learned recently there are
dudes on there that just post shirtless
pics
they just make money off that yeah but i
mean that's still sexual
i know but what's something like you
know we could
you know it's like you know like this
like like the cooking thing
yeah yeah but like like are is there
anyone that posts content on only fans
that's literally not sexual we've talked
about this 5 000 times already but
there has to be it has to be we should
we should do that on a bonus we should
deep dive only fans prefer
non-sexual yeah all of the people on
patreon are like just [ __ ] posted
there
it's the same thing which it is
but for for everyone listening it's way
more convenient
now it'll just be in my feed yeah oh
uh uh i'm trying to think of a
like a only fans performance name
you